más para Donald Trump el expresidente
aseguró que fue inculpado por el caso
Mara lago y dijo ser inocente una trama
jurídica inédita en Estados Unidos
comenzó en mayo de 2021 cuando la
administración Nacional de archivos y
registros se percató que le faltaban
unos documentos cruciales estos se
encontraban en la residencia del
expresidente Donald Trump la ley de
Estados Unidos Establece que los
mandatarios tienen que devolver los
documentos clasificados Después de
terminar su administración por lo que la
administración Nacional de archivos y
registros pasó el caso al departamento
de Justicia el FBI comenzó la
investigación a principios de 2022
primero Trump devolvió 15 cajas que
incluían 184 documentos clasificados en
mayo de 2022 el FBI y el departamento de
Justicia pidieron que se entregaran los
documentos faltantes un mes después los
abogados de Trump devolvieron 38
documentos adicionales con marcas
clasificadas asegurando que eso era todo
lo que sin embargo el ex mandatario
tenía muchos más en su recinto con una
orden de allanamiento los funcionarios
federales entraron a Mara lago en agosto
de 2022 confiscaron más de 33 cajas en
las que había otros 100 documentos
clasificados Trump enfrentará al menos
siete cargos entre los que se encuentran
espionaje conspiración y falso
testimonio el fiscal general Maryland
nombró un abogado especial Jack Smith
para que se hiciera cargo de la
investigación en noviembre creo
firmemente que los procesos normales de
este departamento pueden gestionar todas
las investigaciones con integridad Pero
según la normativa la circunstancias
extraordinarias que se dan aquí
requieren el nombramiento de un abogado
especial para este asunto Smith es
fiscal jefe de la haya y tiene
experiencia en Casos de corrupción en
sus manos está la investigación que
podría enfrentar a Trump por primera vez
a cargos federales